[Music]
hashtag Tommy posting the image of the
radar gun that picked him up throwing 61
miles per hour with the quote he's gonna
fall off a cliff so I'm right like hey
get your motivation wherever you can
bottom line is he's gonna be 42 fairly
soon and there's been no quarterback
that has performed as well as he has
that deep into his career and and a day
to do it but go ahead didn't they do
that last year they perceive that
everyone counted them out even though no
one counted them out like who counts
them out we've learned not to count them
out but they still convinced themselves
if they're being counted out so they can
get motivated to go out and win it's one
of the genius moves by Bill Belichick he
somehow finds a way to get a six-time
Super Bowl champion quarterback and a
six-time Super Bowl champion head coach
and the entire team and organization to
feel like underdogs when they're not and
that's credit to them
I mean if getting that in the locker
room and getting people to think that
you know yet people are counting us out
and we're still here I think was their
hashtag that's that is that's a big part
of the game motivating your team and
keeping people hungry you see it many
many times when a team wins a title and
it's the you know disease of more and
they they fall off right after the
Patriots are not that case when they
lose when they win however the last
season ended they closed the books on it
forget about and they move on to the
next season we're gonna move on to some
of the props that we have for this
morning the favorite to win MVP this
year is Patrick mahomes but Tom Brady
Carson Wentz and Philip Rivers are all 7
to 1 to win the award which of those
three guys would you take to emerge with
the trophy I'm gonna go with Philip
Rivers at 7 to 1 I'm gonna go with
Philip Rivers for this reason it's all
about the narrative and we have the
narrative the Phil pers who's never won
an MVP award we had it last year where
there was a little bit of you know that
that probably weak tennis around there
where people started saying hey is this
Philip Rivers year to win an MVP award
he didn't but now he goes into this year
with everyone having that fresh in their
mind that he has not won so I'm always a
big narrative guy what's the story that
people
glom on to what's the story that people
because you can think the MVP award is
all about numbers but it's not it's
about story it's about primetime games
it's having that MVP moment I'm gonna
put Phillip Rivers for 7 to 1 if I had
to pick one of these guys now here's the
thing if I think that Carson Wentz is
likely to stay healthy most of the year
I mean for me the 7 to 1 proposition is
Ken Carson Wentz stay healthy because if
he does I think he wins the MVP award I
think he ends up being spectacular I
think the Eagles are a team we're gonna
be talking about deep into January if he
stays healthy am I willing to make that
bet at 7 to 1 the Carson Wentz stays
healthy and I think I am I think I am
for 7 to 1 I'll take it 4 2 1 3 2 1
maybe not but 7 to 1 yeah because I
think if he stays healthy he does win
the MVP because he was on track to win
it two years ago it's just that he
hasn't been able to stay healthy and if
he's learned anything from the last two
years he's going to avoid some of that
contact and he's gonna be able to play
through December and into January of
course by January doesn't matter
regular-season MVP if he gets through
week 17 I think he's got a good chance
to win it cuz I think the Eagles will be
really good and I think he'll be really
good big cat that's a terrible pick
that's an awful okay I would I would
mark him down let's see
you it's you what you think right now
sitting here June 29th the Carson Wentz
is going to play 16 games you have to
play 16 games to win the MVP I would I
think I'll take 7 to 1 odds that he
would that he played 16 games I think he
does he'll win the MVP I think he's good
enough that if he plays all 16 he is the
MVP let's figure out some sort of a
friendly wager where that it hinges on
Philip Rivers or Carson Wentz winning
MVP if nobody else if it's somebody else
it's a push so we'll figure out
something to make it interesting alright
ok which non quarterback has the best
chance to win the MVP award Ezekiel
Elliott Christian McCaffrey Le'Veon Bell
album chimera are all fifty to one those
are the best odds non quarterback
because it is a quarterback award but
who do you think has the best chance to
win the MVP who isn't a quarterback
alright so you throw out Le'Veon Bell
because I just don't think that's gonna
happen especially with all the talk
about Adam GaSe not you know knowing how
he wants to use them and that marriage
already feels a little rocky I'll throw
out album chimera because I you know
Drew Brees on his team we talked about
story
mine's the MVP hype I think he will get
it over him over alvin kamara
I'm gonna go with Christian McCaffrey
because it's down to Zeke Eliot
Christian McCaffrey Christian McCaffrey
was fantastic last year Cam Newton who
knows how his arm is progressing his
shoulders progressing it feels like a
very underrated story that not a lot of
people are talking about will he be a
hundred percent healthy well guess what
if he's not a hundred percent healthy
he's probably gonna have to dump it down
to his running back a lot and Christian
McCaffrey feels like when we talk about
storylines and narratives last year was
kind of his coming out hey this guy has
arrived it takes a little bit of time
for everyone to catch up to that now
they've caught up he is ready to go for
an MVP type season I agree with you that
Christian McCaffrey could explode this
year as a superstar he had a sneaky
great second season that doesn't get as
much credit as it should but I'm going
off the board I'm going to say Kwan
Barkley because I think the Giants are
gonna realize their only chance this
year is to run the offense through
Barclays like the Vikings used to do
with Adrian Peterson fully embraced
Barkley
he's durable he's effective he can help
give your old quarterback or your young
quarterback some confidence by catching
short passes and running with them and
gaining false yardage that goes on to
the quarterback stat sheet running up
the middle just helping a bad team look
better than it is and giving it a chance
to be relevant and and you don't have to
be a playoff team if say quantum
Berkeley has a tremendous performance
rushing and receiving he could set the
single-season record for yards from
scrimmage that could be enough to be the
MVP even if the Giants are just on the
fringes of playoff contention so of
those players and again I don't know
that I'm allowed to go off the board but
I'm going off the board and taking say
Quan Barclay I mean you're not allowed
to go off the board it's very clear what
the question was because all these guys
Mike Mike do you see do you see the
little thing next to him it says all
fifty to one odds do you know that say
quantum Berkeley has better than fifty
to one on so you basically said oh I'm
gonna take the guy who has a better
chance to win MVP and look like a genius
that's not how it works the quarterback
has the best chance to win MVP that's
the question which quarterback which not
quarterback has the best chance to win
MVP but there
50 to 1 odds to 15 to 1 odds is what the
basis for the question they all are even
so you're picking something that's all
even all right under that circumstance
then I'll take McCaffrey along with you
but okay say Barclay has approacheth all
right
to gain 2000 receiving yards in 2019 and
I say that because Amari Cooper told us
earlier this week his goal is 2,000
receiving yards is it him or is it
someone else big cat I'll go I'll go
with one that's probably not you know
you're Julio Jones and you're Antonio
Brown how about Mike Evans how about
Mike Evans in Tampa Bay with you know
the new coaching staff they're gonna air
it out you know that they're gonna air
it out so I'm gonna say Mike Evans
Jameis Winston a little bounce back here
Bruce Arians gets in there the QB
whisperer Mike Evans I think he had
about 1,600 1,500 yards last year so
he's knocking on the door that's a
couple of good games away or you know a
couple more catches each game away from
getting 2,000 yards I'm gonna say Mike
Evans you know that that's exactly the
guy I was thinking of I thought you
would say DeAndre Hopkins who I think
has a chance but if deshaun Watson
doesn't have enough time to throw it to
him but look last year he got sack 62
times and they were still 1,500 and 72
receiving yards for DeAndre Hopkins so
he's one to watch but with Evans the key
number is this 17.7 that's what he
averaged per reception that was the
highest among these guys who are above a
thousand yards receiving he only had 86
catches at 17.7 you only need 112 I say
only like it's easy to do but Julio
Jones had 113 last year if you just get
him the ball more and I think Bruce
Arians will he's gonna have more catches
he's gonna have more yards and I agree
with you Mike Evans is the most likely
to get to 2,000 and I also think that
part of the psychology for these
football players if they hear other guys
talking about a goal like that they they
say hey you know what screw that guy I
can do that and I think that makes Myka
and he's very quiet guy but I think
he'll be quietly motivated to go out
there and do something historic and it
would be historic nobody's ever done
2,000 yards all right what's the safer
bet the Dolphins to make the playoffs
or wait let me start that over again
what's the safer bet the Patriots to
make the playoffs or the Dolphins to
fail to make the playoffs New England is
minus 850 to make it and Miami is plus
1200 to make it who I mean this is I'd
say it's about the exact same right I
mean the the dot the Patriots go to make
the playoffs and dolphins are gonna miss
the playoffs I guess if I had to pick
the safer bet would be the Dolphins not
making the playoffs because you could
make the argument that if somehow Tom
Brady got hurt that the Patriots could
somehow miss the playoffs but the
Dolphins there's nothing the Dolphins
can do to make the playoffs in 2008 19
2020 I want that quote to be thrown out
there I want the Dolphins to use that as
motivation let's see if you guys could
do it
my lions quote from a few weeks ago was
motivation for them so the Dolphins have
zero point zero percent chance 2019 NFL
season you know here's the thing though
in recent years there has been a team or
two every season where I have felt very
confident saying that team has no chance
the Browns a couple of years ago they
were the Raiders a few years back no
chance of making the playoffs and you
always feel that little twinge of them
maybe I'm stepping into something here I
can't say it about the Dolphins this
year because I think Brian Flores could
come in and shake that team up and it
doesn't take many lucky bounces to take
a team that really hasn't been nearly as
bad as people believe and turn it into a
contender somebody from that AFC East
other than the Patriots is going to be
in the mix for a wild card berth and we
assume it's gonna be the bills of the
Jets maybe it will be the Dolphins so
you said it not we the safer bet is New
England making the playoffs though all
that said I'd rather put my money on New
England making it from the Dolphins not
making it hold on you just said someone
in the AFC East has to be in the mix for
that wild-card spot that's just
factually not correct why does somebody
know why why you haven't you have it in
the AFC North you have the AFC North you
have the Ravens the Steelers the Browns
all those teams I miss being in the mix
I miss okay I misspoke Saul's in others
been debating between the bills and the
Jets one of those teams we believe is
going to be in the conversation so I
left that
part of it out the dolphins themselves
into that conversation all right seems
worked on Fridays we wouldn't have these
issues
III AFC has a lot of good teams if you
go through it like I said the Ravens the
Steelers the Browns the Titans the
Texans the Jaguars might have a
bounce-back with Nick Foles and then you
go out to the AFC West you get the
Chiefs the Chargers and you know I think
one of the Broncos or Raiders is gonna
be good so to think that you know any of
those other three teams the AFC East
will have anything to say about the
playoffs that's that's a big leap for me
I just love it that the closest you'll
ever come to acknowledging the jettison
of Blake bortles by the Jaguars is that
they may have a bounce-back with Nick
falls I like my progress
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports